okay we're going for like a [ __ ]  wedding we're going for Victoria okay  okay and I guess that is the closest  okay I got this way wait I'm just Lynne  subscribe protection the wedding I'm an  amazing day this has been I hope you've  been enjoying the festival there's  nothing fun I'm just so overwhelmed  kindness yes let me be trying to get  Skyrim innkeepers can let's say you and  your defense ass gonna take me to jail  in a murder / in Riften some old ladies  run to Norton support oh no that's weird  happy therefore I write a sly star yeah  there's a slice sent out  hahaha with v cheese murder you've  started us down a path the dark and now  your reward unfortunately in your zeal  you failed to eliminate vici while she  addressed her guests as directed I'm  sorry but your bonus is forfeit now then  time to proceed to the next stage of the  plan recurrent speak with Gabriella  she's been helping me arrange your next  contract ha ha ha ha thank you